- Ahhh!
It's burning!
Not in this kitchen.
This is how much I love my mother-in-law.
Today, I'm going to be
cooking a Haitian plate
for my Haitian mother-in-law
for the first time.
I have high hopes.
I know I've burnt tortillas
in the past, rice too,
but I'm sure this is
going to turn out amazing
and she's going to love it
but we'll let her be the judge of that.
(Sheryl laughs)
- You should wear a hair tie,
because your hair going
to fall all over the food.
- So I'm going to put my hair up.
Let's disregard that.
So we're going to start
with the easiest thing.
Oh my gosh, I was going to say tostones.
(beep)
What are they called again?
Okay. A banana fri
(buzzer sound)
they, what?
- [Man] Banana fri.
(beep)
- Banan free.
(Sheryl laughs)
(beep)
The banan fri.
(harp sound)
(chopping sound)
It fell inside, it fell inside!
Hold up, hold up, hold up!
Okay. It's fine.
See? This is why this is here.
Protection.
(chopping sound)
(clears throat)
No pressure.
She's coming right over.
I'm doing fine, sure.
Are you doing good?
Okay, this hurts.
- [Mother-In-Law] You want me to show you?
(upbeat music)
- Ooooohhhh.
- [Mother-In-Law] You see?
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- [Husband] Okay. Captain America.
(inspirational music)
(pot frying loudly)
- It's ready.
It's definitely ready.
When I do this to myself
I'm going to impress people with these.
The more pressure you put, the
better, the better it gets.
What?!
Still really good.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
(sparkle sounds)
- [Husband] Ah ah ah ah!
- Oh!
We're dipping it back inside.
This is painful.
Does your mom do this all the time?
How does she deal with the burns?
- [Husband] She just goes in.
- You're not cooking
right if it doesn't hurt.
So now we're going to do chicken and sauce
which is called Poulet En Sos.
The traditional Haitian way is to rub it
with lemon and then you
rinse it off with hot water.
We're going to make our epis.
Do you get dizzy from cutting onion?
- [Husband] No.
- Oh my God. Hold on.
(beep)
(dramatic music)
- This is how much I
love my mother-in-law.
I'll cut an onion for her.
(beep)
(dramatic music)
I can't see anything.
(piano music)
- [Husband] Hello darkness my old friend.
(blender whirring)
- [Sheryl] Delicious.
- [Husband] Worth every tear.
(sizzling pan)
- I feel like it's finally
starting to come together.
Why is it looking black?
- [Husband] 'Cause it's burning.
- Oh my Gosh.
I think it's too high.
Oh, it's burning, It's burning again.
Come on.
You're not burning today.
Not in this kitchen.
(upbeat music)
- [Husband] Don't mix it in.
- Wait, why don't I stir it?
- [Husband] You let it sit first.
- It looks so good.
Wow. I actually want to eat it.
I didn't think I was going
to want to eat my own food.
(downbeat jazz)
- [Sheryl] What do you feel
about your daughter-in-law
cooking for you for the first time?
(laughs)
- That was a surprise.
I'm grateful.
The rice look like a
needs a little bit of TLC.
(laughs)
The plantain, I like the plantain.
You know I can see, you
know, something is good.
Is well-done.
(chewing sound)
That's good.
And, let's go for the meat.
Mm-hmm. Very good.
The rice, the main dish.
(laughs)
The mother of the Haitian food.
(chewing sounds)
(laughs)
The rice is not cooked well,
completely, fully.
(buzzer sounds)
Just to be honest.
That's my honest opinion.
With a little bit of small salt, you know,
and yes there is no salt in there at all.
- [Sheryl] You have to rate
the plantain one through 10.
What would you rate it?
- Eight.
- [Sheryl] How about the chicken?
- Very good, a good nine and ten.
The rice, I will give
you four, for effort.
(laughs)
When we having party at home,
Sheryl cook the chicken.
Going to work on the rice though.
Thank you.
It's time to clean now.
(speaking Spanish)
(speaking French)
(jazz trumpet)